bonjour remerciements de l'union
populaire pour avoir voté jean luc
mélenchon a marseille le temps est
pluvieux et maussade
ainsi elle à l'image de l'humeur des
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon le
candidat de la gauche radicale c'est
pénible
c'est fatigant leur candidat a été
éliminé au premier tour mais de justesse
sans limites surtout marseille avec 22%
des voix son parti la france est soumise
s'impose à gauche pour ça qu'on voyait à
vous remercier ils s'en tiennent donc à
remercier leurs électeurs qu'ils sont
nombreux à marseille c'est après tout
dans le centre de la ville que je trouve
la circonscription du député jean-luc
mélenchon que français électeurs au
deuxième tour de la présidentielle
voilà la grande question je n'irai pas
voter parce qu'entre la peste et le
choléra je préfère rester chez moi
franchement on va aller voter parce
qu'on ne veut pas que marine le pen est
mal
votre stratégiques ou abstention ses
électeurs de gauche détermineront en
partie du sort de l'élection bon bien
sûr on a été déçu aux résultats du
premier tour mais ceci dit comme on a
fait un bon score on voit que nos
adversaires politiques sont tous arrivés
tous ces jolis mais sur nous parce
qu'ils demandent ce qu'on va tous faire
d'où les mains tendues comme celle d'
emmanuel macron venu récemment à
marseille où il a promis un deuxième
mandat plus vers nous on fait entendre
le 10 avril dernier dans les urnes un
message fort pour mettre l'environnement
au coeur de notre campagne et des années
à venir pour la france
sur le terrain les alliés du président
espère que cette nouvelle approche leur
permettra de faire des gains est bien
aussi montrer aux français qui les
écoutent et ça se prononcer très
important
on nous a longtemps critiqué et on
écoutait pas il
les français et là on vient répondre à
une demande des français
une consultation menée auprès de plus de
trois cent mille électeurs de la france
insoumise a montré que le tiers d'entre
eux sont prêts à voter pour emmanuel
macron mais les deux tiers n'ont pas
l'intention d'appuyer l'un ou l'autre
des candidats au deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle un vote pour
marine le pen n'était pas une option
dans le cadre de cette consultation jean
luc mélenchon a demandé à ses partisans
de ne pas appuyer l'extrême droite
et pourtant la candidate du
rassemblement national qui veut fédérer
le vote anti macron mise aussi en partie
sur les appuis de jean luc mélenchon ce
rendez vous du 24 avril vous l'avez
compris mesdames et messieurs met face à
face le bloc populaire contre le bloc
élitaire le bloc de ceux attachés à la
sécurité sociale contre le bloc de ceux
attachés au pouvoir de l'argent
pour dimanche alors qu'ils abordent des
thèmes chers à leur formation comme
l'immigration cette année les militants
du rassemblement national met beaucoup
l'accent sur des enjeux économiques et
sociaux comme les retraités pouvoir
d'achat la première urgence c'est de
baisser les prix on arrive plus et des
gens qui sautent des repas et ça c'est
pas possible une première aux gens c'est
lé social il a cassé socialement la
france je pense vraiment emmanuel la
preuve que les gens sont déçus de la
droite ils ont été déçus de la gauche
ils se disent pourquoi après tout ne pas
essayer marine c'est pas mon opinion
c'est pas ma conviction mais je
comprends que certains raisonnements
dans ce sens là
jean-paul un voter pour jean luc
mélenchon au premier tour dimanche il a
l'intention d'annuler son vote bien
triste on aime beau pays on est en train
de le démolir
l'élection présidentielle de dimanche
peu importe son résultat le mettra
visiblement pas fin au désenchantement
d'une partie de l'électorat si raphaël
movie hockey radio-canada marseille